and natalie portman is once again
perfect in my eyes you know I was like I
actually was perfect now she's like you
know engaged in pregnant and now I'm
back in love with her because I'm fickle
[Music]
no strings attached no so this is the
story of two people played by Natalie
Portman and mr. Demi Moore who become
friends with benefits with the
assumption that there will be no drama
amateurs that's right i rated our comedy
about sex buddies starring Natalie
Portman I have died and gone to heaven
because sex scenes involving Natalie
Portman are like eclipses and that's the
actual event for you Twihards you don't
always get to see him and you really
hope you live to get to see one in your
lifetime but be ones the sheer
awesomeness of the situation might just
fry your eyes out if you look right at
it so in this movie Natalie Portman is
actually the cold one who doesn't get
attached no attachment whatsoever it's
pure business and Ashton Kutcher is
actually the mushy romantic one who
cries after whacking it and yes after
the first 30 minutes you know exactly
how this movie's gonna play out but it
doesn't mean it's not enjoyable I mean
the dialogue was funny and the realism
of it just actually made me laugh cuz
you watch the movie and you just go yeah
people like just like that and what
really surprised me is the supporting
characters they all made me laugh to
like everyone from Ashton Kutcher's
douchebag dad played by Kevin Kline to
that really creepy Asian dude who would
take pictures with his cell phone l made
me laugh I like that because you know is
a little things in comedy like you know
laughter as for Ashton Kutcher art why
does he always get cast as a really
mushy romantic dives in these comedies
it just feels like he walked off the set
of valentines day met up with Natalie
Portman cameras kept rolling and now
he's a different character although he's
pretty much the identical character I
mean he wasn't horrible but in this
movie like a Sam Worthington could have
played his character would have made no
difference
I just think Natalie Portman made the
movie and her dialogue was funny she's a
really good actress I mean we all saw
that in Black Swan the fact that she is
a more perfect version of an already
perfect Natalie Portman who now does not
get attached I just think I'm in love so
I thought it was really funny and really
realistic people do act like this
especially the part where they're all
being dumbasses
so I would say go see it with a date
even though the formulas really familiar
it's still a good time no alcohol
required the director of Ghostbusters
comes through I didn't know that till
the end credits so that surprised me but
it also explains why it's put together
well but if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more or you
also want
Natalie Portman click right here to see
more
[Music]